democrats
consider this issue of talking about
sexual issues
and specifically talking about sexual
issues with little kids the democrats
consider that
sacred
just the other day
was was literally crying over the
prospect of not transiting the kids
the political
games and harsh and cruel
attempts at laws or laws that we're
seeing in some states like florida that
is not a reflection of the country
moving to oppose lgbtq plus communities
that is not what we see in data that is
not factual and that is not where things
stand this is a political wedge issue
and an attempt to win a culture war and
they're doing that in a way that is
harsh and cruel uh to a community of
kids especially i'm i'm like going to
get him i'm going to get emotional about
this issue because i just it's horrible
but uh
but you know it's it's like kids who are
bullied and
like all these leaders are taking steps
to hurt them and hurt their lives and
hurt their families and you look at some
of these laws in these states and it is
going after parents who are in loving
relationships who have kids it's
completely outrageous um but it is it is
a wedge issue sorry i and this this is
an issue that makes me completely crazy
um but it is an issue that um is a
political wedge issue it is not a
reflection of where the country is
this is an issue that makes me
completely crazy is the truest statement
that jen jensaki has ever said obviously
she's crazy the woman
is crying
over the prospect
of not
transgendering little kids
this is a sacred issue to the libs
sometimes when when we talk about this
the libs will accuse us of wearing
tinfoil hats and being conspiracy
theorists but it's not the case the libs
have been weirdly obsessed with
sexualizing kids for at least 100 years
now going back to wilhelm reich going
back to
leftist intellectuals and theorists who
have suggested that we we need to
acculturate kids in into sexuality in a
different way and at an earlier stage
bernie sanders bernie sanders who was
almost the democrat nominee twice bernie
sanders wrote weird essays in the 1960s
about how we need to sexualize kids and
allow kids to explore their sexuality
and now you've got democrats waging a
national fight over the
so-called sacred right of a
five-year-old to be indoctrinated into
weird creepy sex stuff this is why we
call them groomers
okay because they are obsessed with this
issue it's the most important one to
them they care about race they care
about class or at least they used to i
actually don't think they care about it
as much anymore they care about but sex
is the issue
go to goodranchers.com
knowles i have been eating good ranchers
probably three times a week i love it
the steaks are phenomenal the chicken is
magnificent they've got some great
seasonings and things on the chicken
chicken's fabulous and then my absolute
favorite are the burgers the wagyu
burgers are really really magnificent i
don't really get how good ranchers works
because the quality is absolutely top
shelf
the prices are extremely low so you can
go in and order this meat just a one-off
get the box of meat it's all american
100 high-quality american meat
and then
you can inflation proof your orders if
you subscribe to good ranchers you get
your price locked in forever i don't
know how it works but i think you should
take advantage of it while this
incredible deal is going on prices for
beef are only going to get higher as the
summer approaches your favorite cuts are
going to be harder to find lock in your
price and supply with good ranchers
right now get your 30 discount on prime
stakes and better than organic chicken
today
goodranchers.com knowles save on the
quality you've been looking for good
ranchers takes all the guesswork out of
the grocery store sources everything
from local farms right to your door use
that code knowles and enjoy your box of
100 american meat and your 30 savings
combat inflation with good ranchers
american meat delivered
you like that clip cool ring the bell
get those notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stutter google
play subscribe to the michael knowles
show podcast leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]